[Music]
happy birthday tasty it's crazy that
you're turning five it's been such an
awesome and fun journey i'm excited to
see where this takes us next
[Music]
hey it's alvin and we're celebrating
tasty's fifth birthday and i'm gonna be
sharing stories about you know moments
and favorite videos from each of those
five years
taking it all the way back to 2015. five
years ago my approach to videos pretty
much the same as the way i make food
videos today i just wanted to make
recipes that i thought were fun and i
thought other people could find fun from
2015 the one recipe that really stands
out to me was the white chocolate magic
ball this idea was inspired by a dessert
that was going viral on instagram so i
set out to recreate it this one was
probably
one of my trickiest recipes because i
had to find a mold that would make sense
it was a journey to figure out that we
needed to use clear plastic ornaments
usually found on christmas trees it was
really a kind of recreate from scratch
moment because there wasn't a lot of
information
on the actual recipe served at the
restaurant
at the time i wasn't making a lot of
desserts so that was completely new i'm
not like a pastry chef or a chocolatier
filming the video is also pretty tricky
because the chocolate melts pretty
quickly
and there's like a little window where
you have to pour it but get the right
collapse from the chocolate ball and i'm
pretty sure i shot that part like 12
times a hole is cut into the bottom and
you can fill it with whatever you like i
chose brownies and fruit and ice cream
once that is all plated a really hot
chocolate ganache or sauce is poured on
top of the cold white chocolate sphere
and the whole thing melts away kind of
like magic
[Music]
2016 tasty was picking up in popularity
food videos were kind of taking over the
internet and it was a really exciting
time one of my favorite recipes in 2016
was spinach dip mozzarella sticks i just
took two things i love to eat at parties
and put them together so for this recipe
it starts off pretty basic we're gonna
make a normal spinach dip with cream
cheese spinach all those nice cheeses
and seasonings and the cool part is that
this spinach tip has a lot more
mozzarella added into the actual dip
itself because after that the mixture
gets spread on a parchment paper it gets
frozen and then cut into rectangular
sticks that are then breaded and then
fried and when it fries the cheese
inside that we added before
melts so that when it pulls apart it's
almost like a mozzarella stick but
there's also spinach dip perfect party
food
2017
one of my favorite recipes this year was
the jiggly fluffy japanese cheesecake
it's so fluffy oh my god i actually got
the chance to go to japan with rye a
fellow tasty producer we work with the
tasty japan team one popular dish was
this jiggly cheesecake that was that is
probably really well known now but back
then it was like this instagram viral
thing that only a couple of shops were
selling this one is probably
my second hardest video on tasty i've
ever made i made about 15 of these
before i actually figured out the
correct ratios essentially this recipe
is a kind of egg yolk cheesecake batter
that is folded into a bunch of egg
whites so in the beginning it's a lot of
egg yolks it's some cream cheese milk
sugar flour all that nice stuff and that
gets set aside and what happens next is
kind of the core of the cheesecake which
is like a ton of egg whites because the
whole thing what makes it jiggly is the
air that is trapped inside the whipped
egg whites when it bakes so the whole
cheesecake is highly dependent on really
well whipped egg whites once those are
done the main batter gets folded in and
it gets poured into a large cake pan
that is baked in a water bath for a very
very very long time it's essentially a
giant souffle cake this recipe i think
is pretty satisfying in a lot of
different ways you have the peeling of
the paper you have the way it jiggles
when you set it down and kind of wobbles
around a bit and then the powdered sugar
on top and overall it just looks very
aesthetically pleasing which is why i
think it's very popular and it also
tastes pretty awesome too
[Music]
2018. at this point tasty is expanding
we're trying a lot of different things
we're trying shows we have a lot of
longer form content on youtube and it
was a great time to just try a lot of
cool things i've always had a
fascination for really visual foods so
i decided to make a giant version of a
burger came down to really figuring out
how to make a giant bun a giant slice of
cheese how to make two giant patties the
lettuce and the tomatoes so for me it
was almost like this fun architecture
experiment and seeing you know what
recipes were out there but how that
looked like if i multiplied it by 10 or
20. so it was a cool process to go
through where i literally had to figure
out what the biggest pan i had was how
big the oven was what the cook times
were and the different solves that you
deal with when food is that large and i
think that was the biggest challenge but
also the most fun part of the experience
so people were into that video and after
that i was lucky enough to be able to
produce a whole season of making it big
where you go around and make giant
versions of people's favorite foods like
ramen chicken nuggets sushi pizza so
that was a really fun time
2019.
i was experimenting a lot more with
different kinds of videos i wanted to
showcase a lot of chefs instead of doing
everything all the cooking myself so i
went out and shot a lot of videos that
are almost documentary inspired
with a lot of chefs i did a couple ones
with a mozzarella master a chinese hand
poodle noodle master a japanese soba
master
and i will probably say my favorite one
that i've ever produced was the one with
a sushi master i wanted to showcase what
it was like to be one of the elite
craftsmen in his field not just the way
he cooks but also the the parts that
lead up to it that a lot of people don't
see the most interesting thing is that
he is only open for dinner for 16 people
every night that's the maximum but
there's so much work that goes on in the
morning late night even the day before
that i think was really important to
show shooting that video was an
experience as well his
whole restaurant was essentially like
this temple we made sure not to bump
into anything you know all the wood was
imported from japan we had to be very
careful with our camera equipment we
didn't want to intrude on his work we
just wanted to sit there capture
everything silently the way he would do
it normally and it was a really cool
balance to not only get the chance to
film a master like him but to appreciate
his work through the lens of a camera
and 2020 this year we really wanted to
show that
you can do so much with cooking at home
and this is the first time i really
focused on giving glimpses into the
actual people behind the camera and the
recipes to show how they actually cook
at home
i've been a fan of a lot of korean and
japanese youtube food craters they have
pioneered the style of a food cinematic
vlog that uses subtitles and music and
the sounds of cooking to kind of make a
video very relaxing i'm i was really
inspired by those videos i think cooking
with three ingredients
is really fun because there's this
challenge of making a dish that people
might know but with way less ingredients
so it automatically makes things more
accessible to new cooks who might be
trying recipes or cooking for the first
time and it also is easier since you
don't have to go grocery shopping for 20
bajillion things and this is kind of
magic science behind why certain three
ingredients um can come together to
create something that usually would take
20. so i like that part of it a lot in
this video i also took inspiration from
a korean trend which is the whipped
talagona coffee
i made a fluffy souffle jiggly omelette
again with a lot of asian influence i'm
a teriyaki chicken the way i would
usually make it for myself to eat on a
daily basis
and i made creme brulee which i used a
trick from my friend rye who uses melted
ice cream
to substitute for all the eggs and the
sugar so it was a fun
food packed day but not that many
ingredients
[Music]
so there you have it those are some of
my favorite videos from my five years
at tasty happy birthday tasty and here's
the five more
oh yes
[Music]
you